[Music]
thank you
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to deconstruct
world-class performers from all
different disciplines could be chess
could be military in this case it is
games all things gaming my guest today
is Elon Lee you can find them on Twitter
at ilon Lee e l a n l e e Alan is the
co-creator and chief executive officer
of exploding kittens maybe you've heard
of it a leading gaming and entertainment
company under his leadership exploiting
kittens has expanded its portfolio to
nearly 30 different games with more than
20 million games sold in more than 50
countries since its founding in 2015.
before founding exploding kittens Lee
was the chief design officer at Xbox
entertainment Studios where he led the
interactive entertainment portfolio
prior to that he was the founder and
chief created officer of fourth wall
Studios and co-founder of 42
entertainment he began his career at
Microsoft game studios as a lead
designer on the original Xbox Lee has
won a Primetime Emmy for the series
Dirty Work game innovator of the year
for exploding kittens a Peabody Award
for the world's first alternate reality
game the Beast and an indicate
Trailblazer award for a distinguished
career in interactive entertainment
among others
Alan welcome to the show nice to see you
thanks it's really good to see you too
happy to be here
so to paint a picture for folks
downstairs I have what should function
as a dining table completely covered in
games of of every imaginable type and
the floor is further littered there are
our dice everywhere there are blank dice
everywhere cards there are blank cards
so I'm in the midst of immersing myself
in all things specifically tabletop
gaming and I want to thank you because
of all the games tested so far
one game has stood out as a friend
favorite and that is poetry for
neanderthals and there are people out
there who will catch me on neanderthals
and fine I'll say it both ways for you
yeah we asked for that one naming that
fair enough yeah so I'm hoping we could
start because I've listened to quite a
few interviews with you and there are
other places where some of your bio has
been covered in I think a very very good
fashion I recommend people listen to
think like a game designer in the
episode that Justin Gary did with you
yeah as well but why don't we start
because I found a video online which was
you interviewing two game designers who
worked on hand-to-hand wombat and I
found that short conversation so
incredibly helpful with the nitty-gritty
of seeing how the sausage is made I was
hoping that perhaps we could start with
poetry for neanderthals as a case study
yeah from the very Inception and you
could just walk us through it yeah
absolutely so
poetry for neanderthals it didn't even
have a name of course no game has a name
when you start but that one came to me
from some friends I met Jacob and
Francesca at this conference and they
came to me and they're like okay you're
the exploding kittens guy we got this
really cool idea what if there was a
game where you had to learn a new
language and you're really bad at that
language you're in a foreign land
everyone speaks the language except you
and you've got to try to get by and they
said the way that we can simulate you
not speaking the correct language is you
have the Restriction every sentence you
speak every word in that sentence must
be a single syllable word and they gave
me some examples they're like okay so
now listen you Elan you have to say
I'm really hungry I want to go to the
store but there's a dragon at the store
that's really scary and I don't know
what to do
go and I'm like I'm like okay okay sure
me want to go get food and immediately I
realized oh I sound like a caveman
that's kind of fun that's you're right
you have simulated this this environment
where I don't speak the right language
and so
we started working together and it took
about a year of of playing around we got
another designer involved a guy named
Brian Spence and realized there's
something super fun here like there's a
core gameplay Loop there's something
that every time people touch it every
time they they play around with it they
start laughing they start wanting to
tell their friends about it but holy
crap those sentences they are a mouthful
and so we took the sentences down to
like five or six words still too much we
took them down to three words still too
much took them down to two words still
too much and we finally realized like
why are we complicating this what if the
entire game was get your friend to say
this word using only single syllable
words and that was it once we realized
that we were bringing baggage through
for no reason the game got really simple
really fun my co-founder and business
partner Matt Inman who's the creator of
the oatmeal he took one look at it and
said we're calling this thing poetry for
neanderthals and suddenly we had a game
it was really like those steps in that
order that let us push that thing out
the door
and could I just maybe give a Layman's
take so people can Envision what this
game looks like so I played it with two
other friends it was the three of us and
I I actually we did a lot of trial and
error so I think we also did some
experimental work just in terms of how
to optimize for three people but imagine
that you have one person who is the
caveman or cave woman and they have
these cards and you flip over the card
and at the top you have ghost let's just
say as an example that's and that will
get you one point if you can give cues
in these monosyllabic words only you can
see that word nobody else can yeah
that's right only you can see the word
and so you might say dead man
it starts to get hard very quickly and
if you get that right now you can say
the word ghost you're allowed to say
that and so the three point which is the
three-point option below that might be
Ghost Town let's just say and there is a
hourglass that is turned over
which gives you I think it's maybe 60
seconds uh yeah something like that to
rack up as many points as possible
usually you do this in teams if you
break the rules and you say something
like Casper there's somebody with an
inflatable club which does not hurt
who whacks you on the head with this
saying or I guess on some other body
part and so with three guys adolescent
at heart even though this is designed I
think for ages seven and up we just got
hours and hours of endless fun out of
this thing it was so much fun because
you also have these ridiculous things
that come up my brother's wife so my
sister-in-law was trying she had mouth
mouth was the one point word and she
said teeth house and he was like Teeth
house like the stuff that comes out can
be really really funny that's so good
and it's very easy to get up and running
quickly which is what made this I think
more attractive than some of the other
games I bought at game shops which were
very
a much heavier lift on the way in and I
want to just as a way of setting the
table tell people part of the reason I
was excited to have you on and we
chatted a bit before recording and you
and I are aligned on
I'm sure quite a few things but one is
helping people and I'll include myself
in that group to spend less time in
front of screens yeah and games are a
very easy way to do that if you find the
right games and you choose the right
tool to suit your personality and those
are the friends that you have
so I jumped in and and gave a TED Talk
there for a second so thanks for putting
up with that but hold on let me let me
just interject what you just described I
mean you're hired that was the perfect
commercial what you just described is a
game that's not necessarily entertaining
but a game that allowed those three
people you included to entertain each
other and that's that's music to Mayors
like that means okay success we built a
cool game there that was the goal we hit
it I didn't even have to be in the room
to facilitate that you just had exactly
the experience I wanted you to have I'm
thrilled absolute win yeah yeah so let
me dive into a few of the stages
so you you met the game designers who
you named and what led you to want to
work with them because you must both
personally and as a company I would
imagine get pitched a lot of new games a
lot yeah so what was it besides the
concept because ideas are worth
something but they're not worth as much
as people like to think yeah so what was
it that led you to want to commit to
working with them and then what capacity
was that and then what happened over
that year was it simply that everyone
had a lot of projects they were juggling
and that had to fit in the gaps right or
something else okay so we gotta take a
little bit of a look at sort of the
anatomy of a game and
what that means is I believe the most
important part of a game is I don't have
a great term for it I'm actually I have
no training in game design so I kind of
make all this stuff up along as I go so
bear with me but and they're doing fine
in life yeah thanks making it up as you
go so keep doing what you're doing yeah
we'll do all right I think at the
essence of any game is what I at least
call the the core gameplay Loop and
that's the thing that you're gonna do
over and over and over again so in the
case of exploding kittens the core
gameplay Loop is Russian roulette with a
deck of cards right like there's a few
bad cards in there draw a card hope it's
not the bad one you survive to see
another day core gameplay loot
Uno right classic game everybody knows
you know if I had to describe the core
gameplay loop I would say it's a lock
and key mechanism and and all that means
is like you have a hand of cards
everyone's a key as soon as you play a
key on top of a lock which is in the
center of the board it becomes a new
lock for the next player that's the core
gameplay Loop right in that case it's
numbers and colors but still it's just
locks and keys and playing one converts
one
so
that concept of finding a core gameplay
Loop that's compelling and interesting
is really hard
really really hard and the ones that I'm
most attracted to when I hear them is
core gameplay Loops that are not
actually entertaining core gameplay
Loops that make the people you're
playing with entertaining because I
really think that's at the heart of
games when I when I think back to like
my childhood and playing games with my
brothers and sisters growing up I don't
remember any of the games because I
don't think I should remember any of the
games the games are not important it's
it's the tool set right those games are
tools for me to have fun with my
siblings and I remember that fun I
remember the the laughter I remember the
the like secret alliances I remember all
that stuff
because the games had really strong core
gameplay Loops that allowed me to have
those interactions all right sorry big
rabbit hole there love rabbit holes I'll
try to keep it short right okay so
that's what long form podcasts are for
yeah fair enough all right so for poetry
when Jacob and Francesca came to me with
this concept I didn't think it was a
good game and just for clarity were they
friends were they out of the blue were
they working for the company in part
time or full-time so this was at a
conference called ORD camp in Chicago
it's an invite-only conference so very
few people there I show up crazy
introvert I'm scared out of my mind to
talk to people but there's only 100
people there so anybody who comes up to
me and says hello I'm like okay there's
something cool about this person
otherwise I wouldn't be here so let me
try my best and there's nowhere to hide
and there's nowhere to hide there's
really nowhere to hide so when they
approached me and said hey can we talk
to you I just thought like I need to
give everybody here the benefit of the
doubt I need to get over my shyness I
need to talk to them and it turns out it
was a great idea because
what they showed me like I said was not
a fun game but a really interesting core
gameplay loot this idea that
communication is easy if you reduce it
down to monosyllabic words
communication becomes really challenging
and you need your friends help to get
you from that caveman talk back to
regular English Okay so over that then
year period of time
what is happening just to come back to
sort of the anatomy of the development
of game how do you refine how do you
play test what is play testing all that
kind of stuff so one of the biggest
assets that we have in our company and
the thing that took me like seven years
to build is this program called the
kitty test pilots and this is a group of
families that have reached out to us
saying we love your games tell us when
the next one comes out and we respond
great want to test some prototypes for
us and we regularly send them out very
very half-baked ideas and we asked them
just to send us feedback so what
happened over the next year so we took
that idea I showed it to some friends I
said okay what if you had to translate
these sentences using only single
syllable words and what came back was
holy crap this is cumbersome this is so
hard and there's not enough time and my
turn my turn took eight minutes and what
the hell is that and you know we all
this really bad feedback
but I knew that core gameplay Loop was
really solid so that's when we went down
to like okay what if the sentences were
only five words long what if we reduced
the timer to two minutes then one minute
I think the final is actually only like
45 seconds
don't hold me to that something in that
race something yeah yeah but we started
to realize like I'm getting better and
better results the fewer words they have
to do at once but they want more time to
do a bunch more words So eventually we
got down to all right let's try out two
things one
you only have to do one word at a time
let's see if that's interesting and two
what does punishment mean because
everybody laughs when you use a word
with more than one syllable but then it
kind of ended it was like setting up for
a joke but the punchline never came and
so we thought all right we'll put a
buzzer in there or there's a word you
shout out and I'm pretty sure it was
Matt with his just perfect pitch sense
of humor I said well it's a caveman game
so give him a club and let them Bonk
each other over the head and I'm sure
general counsel love that yeah oh man
you would not believe how lawyers hate
us holy crap endless endless
conversations they made us in the
instructions they made us say you know
hit the other person over the head
softly they insisted on that and so we
put and we changed it without asking we
put it to soft ish over the head that
was our version of a compromise anyway
when we talk about the anatomy of a game
though like we're talking about that
core gameplay Loop okay we really got it
now one word get through as many one
word cards as you can as fast as you can
you've got a few seconds to do so and
now we start to add
you know the
the surroundings around the game we need
to pick really funny words that we know
are going to elicit funny responses
teeth is really great
teeth was calculated
teeth is not just a word that shows up
in that game we had to think like all
right what are words where when you try
to describe them you're going to start
to stumble and the places you have to go
yield really funny results right and
things like teeth start to show up in
the game and then we start thinking
about punishment we started thinking
about the the no stick it's called
because everything in the game is just
single syllables and on and on it went
until we had our core game Loops
surrounded by this really beautiful kind
of menagerie of of things that enhanced
the experience and made it so like
okay you can start playing this game
every single element is gonna push you
towards that core gameplay Loot and the
core gameplay Loop is going to rely it's
the the fuel running that engine that
Loop running over and over again is the
other players and once we hit that in
this beautiful elegant fast loop and
that's when we start throwing that thing
in a box and pushing it out the door
chipping it out so could you give it
another example or two of core gameplay
Loop because on one hand it sounds like
there could be a core gameplay Loop that
is almost like a theme much like you
might have
the Hollywood pitch of say alien which
is Jaws in space right so that's right
right something very simple which
encapsulates
the melding of two ideas that make
something interesting yeah but it could
also be a game mechanic which I know
much less about could you give another
example or two of core gameplay Loop
absolutely I love dissecting games to
find these so I'll start with one of my
own so let's look at exploding kittens
I described it really briefly before as
just Russian roulette with a deck of
cards that's not accurate if we want to
talk about the actual core gameplay Loop
what that game is is Russian roulette
with a deck of cards where you get to
decide where to place the bullet
and that is super important that
actually the very first time we tested
the game it was just here's a deck of
cards there's a few bullets and we
didn't even know what to call at the
time here's there's a few bullets in
this deck we're just going to take turns
drawing someone draws a bullet you're
dead everybody continues on without you
that game was no fun at all and the
reason it was no fun is because it's us
playing against the game the game is the
game has all the burden of entertaining
us absolutely uninteresting
we introduced these other cards into the
game called diffuse cards and all the
diffuse card did was it said look if you
draw that bullet
instead of dying you can put it back in
the deck anywhere you want in secret
now we've got a game because now it's
not ran it's not actually Russian
Roulette it's not a random game you have
to survive me you have to out think me I
just put this thing somewhere in the
deck and now it's your turn to go did I
put it on top maybe you don't want to
draw that card did I put it on the
bottom maybe you don't want to draw that
card did I know that you knew that I
knew that you knew that I didn't put it
on the top and so you skipped your turn
and Drew the second one down well maybe
I knew that right now suddenly the game
Fades away and I'm playing against you
and that's the core gameplay Loop of
exploding kittens and I believe why it's
been so successful
so we're going to bounce all over the
place which is I guess I'm gonna I'm
gonna make it a feature and not a bug of
my style of conversation
but let's chat if you're open to it
about Kickstarter for a moment because I
know a lot of people outside of
games specifically will still be
interested in Kickstarter or
crowdfunding in general so you I believe
at one point had a fraud alert email
printed out and framed because I think
somewhere the limit was set like 10 000
and maybe got bumped like 50 000 for
this new bank account for things yeah
what was your initial Target for the
kickstarter campaign and where did you
end up the initial Target was we were
trying to raise ten thousand dollars in
30 days
and we set that alert like the bank
would let us deposit a check up to fifty
thousand dollars they were being very
generous and the check that we tried to
deposit at the end of those 30 days was
almost nine million dollars
okay I have specific questions around
how you did things differently and you
had some some very strong advantages
going in right you had your background
you had Matt and the oatmeal and all the
followers of the oatmeal yeah so you had
you had a deck that was loaded in a
sense but still ended up being maybe
still is the most backed in terms of
number of backers Kickstarter project or
at least at the time that was the case
still the case by a lot actually in
order to talk about Kickstarter we have
to talk about two things one is
alternate reality games and the other is
the oatmeal yep so alternate reality
games like my background being sort of
trained at Microsoft and at the Xbox and
learning about communities and the
appeal of games and and why we play
games together
I then went off and started with some
friends this company to build alternate
reality games and all you really need to
know about alternate reality games
although I could talk about them for a
long time is
the central premise is
together you are stronger together as a
community you can do stuff you can
become extraordinary versions of
yourselves and the games are set up to
deliver a story out in the real world
that is convoluted
and you have to piece it back together
it's like my my mentor Jordan Weissman
likes to call it internet archeology so
archeology is
you find all the little bits and pieces
of the vas you put it together in order
to figure out what it is about that
Society how that Society lived how those
people lived
alternate reality games are the same
thing we write a beautiful Story start
to finish
with a very compelling narrative and
then we break it up into little pieces
and we hide those pieces everywhere in
the real world on the internet on phone
lines fax lines live actors everywhere
and you the audience working together
because you're stronger together go and
perform that feat of archeology find all
the pieces put them back together look
at your beautiful digital vas and then
learn the story
based on based on what you found
so I built a lot of those and I was
really trained
over and over again really beaten into
my psyche Community First Community
First they're so much smarter than you
are learn to entertain a crowd that's
what this is all about
all right
we decided to launch this Kickstarter
campaign we had this really
compelling hook we knew the game was
really good we put up the page and the
very first thing that happens is the
oatmeal goes into full effect Matt has
spent at that point about a decade
building an audience earning their trust
convincing them that like he does just
really high quality work and for those
who don't know could you did just
explain what the oatmeal yes so at that
point what it looked like yeah so at
that point the oatmeal was and still is
a web page the oatmeal.com and Matt has
spent 10 years writing short form comedy
one panel sometimes up to four panel
Comics very few long-form pieces where
he tells stories about his childhood or
he it's a lot of social commentary and
they're hilarious they're beautiful some
of them have won Eisner Awards they will
make you cry
he is Matt is truly one of the most
talented artists and comedians I've ever
met and yeah he's a guy who's just so
much smarter than I am it's an
incredible collaboration and I got to
meet him through a mutual friend I
pitched this game to him we talked about
it he said he'd really like to help and
and off we went
and when we launched the kickstarter
campaign honestly it was only like three
weeks after I met him wow that's fast
yeah really fast we built this didn't
realize that was yeah that it was that
fast we built it fast because we had
nothing to lose we we didn't think it
would be a huge success we just thought
this feels really good we don't have to
overthink this let's just go is it fair
to say that also at that point you had
the game mechanics refined
and Matt was bringing in
a lot of the sort of artistic comedic
Flair in terms of the back hair cards
and the artwork so you're effectively
adding art to game mechanics that were
ready to go yeah but kind of lacked an
artistic vehicle is that fair totally
fair there are 56 cards in the game and
so Matt's task was not to design the
game although we both worked hard to to
refine it
Matt's task was write 56 one panel jokes
and and he did like you flipped through
that deck and the first thing you're
going to do is just just laugh I mean
it's it's such beautiful art yeah
okay so back to our story we launched
the kickstarter campaign and Matt post
about it he says for the first time ever
I've done a game I hope you like it and
millions of people showed up like like
literally millions of views to that
Kickstarter page and our first we got
funded we're trying to raise ten
thousand dollars we got funded in like
seven minutes I mean it was it was out
of control and our first day we made a
million dollars and our second day we
had two million in our third day we had
three million and it was just like this
is this is a runaway train like we have
certainly caught lightning in a bottle
we've we've we have unleashed the full
potential of the oatmeal here's finally
a way to productize that incredible
brand welcome exploding kittens to the
world
but then after the first week
after the first week it fell off a cliff
and the reason is is just because
everyone who Matt could reach who was
interested in this thing had taken a
look either made a purchase decision or
not and that was it you know the the
tank was empty
so
I sat down with him and we're like well
we got two choices we can either just
sort of ride off into the sunset and say
we made like four million bucks that's
incredible we're trying to raise ten
thousand let's just you know Take a Bow
and and we're done
or we could try to push this thing a
little bit and and just see what else is
possible on Kickstarter and I kind of
at the time
wow this is long-winded but I guess so
so into this stuff so bear with me
at the time the way that Kickstarter
worked the kind of only lever you had
were these things called stretch goals
and the way a stretch goal works is you
say look I got this product I'm gonna
charge you 20 bucks for it
and we're going to try to raise ten
thousand dollars but if we raise twenty
thousand dollars for free everybody gets
three more bonus cards and if we raise
fifty thousand dollars you get a
carrying case and if we raise a hundred
thousand dollars you know you gold
plated cards whatever it is
that was the tool you had give us more
money we'll give you more [__]
we decided that's going to be the name
of this podcast episode
when we looked at that ecosystem with
that one lever give us more money we'll
give you more [__]
we kind of thought like there's got to
be something else we can do there's got
to be something else and I I suddenly
like my eyes went wide and I realized
holy crap I've been training for this
moment my whole damn life yeah like we
need to activate the community instead
of thinking this is you know crowd
funding listening to this is crowd
funding right yeah so we did Stretch
goals just like everybody else but
instead of tying it to money we tied it
to
just insane [__] that we could ask the
backers to do we basically said look
we're going to throw a party and
everybody's invited
instead of giving us more money we're
done with money instead hey we got this
character in our game called taco cat
half cat half Taco show us a picture of
a real taco cat
and if you do if like 10 people do that
we'll throw in 10 extra cards that's a
stretch goal you know it would be funny
give us a picture of 10 Batmans in a hot
tub whatever the hell that means we want
to see it somebody does that we'll give
you a fancy carrying case and we just
went nuts we wrote These challenges that
were insane and and funny and
basically said we we just want to have
fun please have fun with us this is
going to be we're only here for another
20 days so why don't we just celebrate
the whole way through
and the audience jumped on it and they
they did everything we asked they they
took those pictures they wrote poems
they filmed videos they went out on the
streets they met each other they had
they had parties together they ordered
pizza like all the fun stuff because we
basically said money doesn't matter
anymore let's just have fun and it was a
great invitation all right so many
places I want to go with this and of
course you are all of all of this
alternate reality training for this
sudden IRL Olympics it was brought to
bear that's right Kickstarter the first
is just to put in context the the money
doesn't matter comment because it seems
like at the time you're around four and
you made additional millions of dollars
is that because there was a pre-order
button on the page yeah and as Buzz
built even though the tiers weren't
predicated on people
spending more money you had more new
orders coming in as the buzz around
these challenges and so on traveled
that's exactly right we didn't we didn't
ask for more money we just said this is
the page where we're going to use this
page as Mission Control this is where
we're going to put out all the new
challenges this is where we're going to
tell you what you've earned when those
challenges are complete none of those
challenges again have anything to do
with money
but because it's a Kickstarter page
there's also a back this project button
right there and so the dollar is kept
rolling in yeah I love this because
you're doing what
I think it is is so beautiful when it
works and I want to ask you more about
it because I'm sure you have more
thoughts which is how do you turn
say casual fans into super fans super
fans into proselytizers yeah and then
you basically and I know this is
simplified but if you do that well you
basically don't need a PR marketing
department to the extent that you would
otherwise right absolutely
now you have them doing all sorts of
stuff so pets disguised as fighter jets
real unicorn enchiladas and and it goes
on and on and on the second major
question that I have is how did you
track all of this stuff because it seems
like at least in today's in today's
social media environment perhaps it's
just it's more scattered now and is more
centralized then but how did you keep
track of all this stuff and I guess you
don't need to keep track of all of it
because really you're saying if we get
10 Batmans in a tub and we get 10 of
those
yeah unlock yeah exactly we tracked it
very very poorly like like we had a two
sort of arguably three-person team at
that point so it was arguably three
percent yeah well some friends of mine
would sort of like you know drift in and
drift out in their spare time right
right right I'll tell you I learned
something amazing we had a Gmail account
associated with Kickstarter page oh boy
and apparently there's a limit if a
Gmail account receives a certain number
of emails over a particular amount of
time that Gmail account gets shut down
no no turns out that number is 10 000
per second oh wow and we hit that trap
holy [__] yeah yeah
so you do you just assume you're like
all right we're not going to read 10 000
a second we assume there's some Batman's
in a tub in there so [__] [__] it we
were planning on being able to deliver
anyways let's just so we didn't let's do
it so you asked the question like how do
you convert those casual fans into super
fans yeah the way you do that is you
don't make those assumptions you
actually do need to read through those
emails because the conversion process is
shining a light on them like yeah
totally you have to right you have to
send out an update that says look what
you did and you have to have the
pictures right there and like yeah the
first draft of that of that update said
look what happened and we realized whoa
that's the wrong message it has to say
look what you did nothing to do with us
nothing to do with just facts you you
spotlight on you and that's when people
started to convert because they're like
oh alternate reality training we are
more powerful together we are a
community let's all keep working
together
you've learned a lot and I'm sure that
the approach you take to Distributing
your games has changed over time since
once you establish yourself it's like
once you're guns and roses and you've
had Appetite for Destruction like the
way you approach things is a little
different right yes yeah but I've read
you elsewhere warn which I thought was
very astute so I'll mention it here and
then I'd love for you to maybe flesh it
out a bit warn people about stretch
goals where for instance they're like
we're going to give a T-shirt and it's
like well wait a second how much
experience do you have with
manufacturing fulfillment skus multiple
sizes and if you have a tabletop game
it's it's hard enough to learn how to be
in the tabletop business if you're new
let alone deciding you're gonna have
also a t-shirt business to try to figure
out not to mention the distraction cost
are there any other best practices slash
pitfalls that you had worn against well
first of all that that's so true I
haven't looked at the numbers recently
but there was a time about like two or
three years ago when I looked at the top
10 Kickstarter campaigns of all time and
we were you know we're always in that
list somewhere people people are
constantly beating our record they
haven't beat our number of backers but
certainly made more money than we have
and I looked at the top ten and of those
10 we were the only Company still in
business wow and it's because before
that much money comes in to earn that
much money there is this incredible
temptation to Branch out and to become a
t-shirt company and send out posters and
say we're going to hand autograph every
single instance of this thing and it's
it's such a mistake right like you are
being backed to focus on fulfilling one
item just do that just stop stop trying
to like give people more party favors
stop trying to be more popular like the
way you make those friends is by
fulfilling the promise you made to those
people and it's very rare that people
adhere to that it's such a shame
so I I'm going to I'm just I've been so
excited to talk to you man I really
appreciate you making the time and
despite despite my caveat at the
beginning before we started recording
which is I think I'm having an allergic
reaction I'm actually slowly like
pulling it together going from my
zombification earlier to semi-coherent
so thank you my pleasure I want to give
you
credit where credit is due there are
many ways I could do that but top 10 to
still be in the top 10 of all time
is remarkable for a lot of reasons one
of which is as Kickstarter gains in
popularity it is not an apple Apples to
Apples comparison in the same way that
if you have if you look at say the top
100 box office earners of all time from
a film perspective it's very hard to
compare something from the 50s or 60s
with say 1990 because of
theater penetration inflation right
that's a thing totally prices go up so
it's astonishing that you guys have had
that degree of longevity and part of why
I think you have been and this is
speculation but part of why I think
you've been so successful and not just
once but multiple times is you're very
good at applying positive constraints
well said so I would love to know for
instance as a company right so it's one
thing to go from
a successful project to fulfilling that
project and a lot of people are killed
just in that process
it's quite another to build out a
company that then
expands raises funding takes on private
equity and has done everything that you
guys have done which is it's very rare
what are some of the constraints because
if I look at your games right I look at
the the form factor the size like it
seems like there are there's thought put
into maybe the maximum size I don't know
then I look at the complexity and I'm
like okay we're not dealing with like
metal figurines
how do you think about
the parameters that you place on your
games
oh there's so much to talk about here
let's do it one of them
okay you open a game box and I'm gonna
break that down into two parts there's
the game components and then there's the
Box itself
first let's talk about the Box itself
because it's this ridiculous conundrum
if you were to go and buy a new iPhone
that box is beautiful and expense they
spend like 10 or 20 or 50 dollars
building that hardboard box and it's
beautifully printed and it's glossy and
you know what you do you take out the
iPhone and you throw the Box away
yep my margins on my box are so tiny
that I need to spend
four cents five cents building that box
and you're gonna take the game out and
then you're gonna play it and you're
gonna put it back in that box and that
box has to survive 20 years like it's
it's insane it is so hard to do and so
first we have to understand play
patterns we have to understand how the
audience actually uses this product and
most games will spend they'll stay
within their margins they'll say well we
can only spend four cents on the box so
we're gonna build it we know the thing's
gonna disintegrate but so be it
we don't have that Approach at all we
lose money on every box and that's cool
we're okay with that yeah because we
know like this is a lifelong commitment
we're making to you now just to be clear
when you say box this is the packaging
surrounding the game you're not saying
on every game correct it's exactly right
we break it down by you know there's a
certain amount of budget allocated to
each component in the box is one of
those
now let's look at the actual components
in the box and I had to learn about all
this stuff I had no idea that there was
such thing as
card thickness or weight of of different
cardboard components did you know
there's a catalog of sand timers that
you can look through they're not all the
same forget like how much time passes
through them but like the quality of the
sand the quality of the plastic it does
it have one layer or two layers like are
they multiple multiple colors have you
dyed the sand
all this stuff and we look at all of it
and
for our Mantra as a company is
opening that box has to be a delight
Like Everything You Touch in there has
to feel beautiful it has to feel like
someone loved this thing
because we're about to ask those players
for a lot we're about to say yeah put
down your phone holy crap put down your
phone read like 15 minutes worth of
instructions that's a huge ask 15
minutes and explain it to everybody else
at the table and then try playing the
game and you're probably gonna screw it
up and read them again and then try it
again like the the dropout rate is
enormous but if they feel like someone
really cares about this thing someone
someone really devoted time maybe
they'll give us more of a chance and so
that's the biggest constraint we place
is we're like okay just put the budget
aside for a second know that what
everybody else does does not really
apply here
we need to make a beautiful product we
need to make something that people fall
in love with as much as we are in love
with it and and that's the translation
our love will equal theirs
so question about size not to get too
personal no but I would imagine that
with the components their materials cost
and that could be just a volume question
right like how much of X material you
are using
the games that I've seen
produced by exploding kittens have all
seemed easy to travel with I don't know
if that is a side effect of other
design principles or if that
is sort of a first principle yeah
do you have games that are much larger
we do we've tried a bunch of things so
when we talk about
when we talk about size there's a few
things to keep in mind travel is huge we
know people want to be able to transport
these things from place to place bring
it to a party bring it to a family
reunion you know that stuff is super
important but when we put a box on a
shelf we're fighting with all the other
games on that shelf and if you think of
a box as a billboard the biggest
billboard is going to win so having a
smaller box is not necessarily
advantageous there but now let me Pitch
the flip side of that which is we got to
ship these things from the manufacturing
plant to a warehouse and
how many boxes can you fit in what's
called a shipper on a pallet and then in
a container right yeah so all of that
matters a lot it's this very delicate
balance what we've started doing because
we prefer smaller boxes
we've started doing deals with retailers
like Target and Walmart to say look
we're going to give you a smaller box
but let us build a
these are called shippers they're
they're big cardboard frames that sit on
the shelf and then the game sits inside
of it so we're trying to get the best of
both worlds right big billboard lots of
presents on the Shelf but the game is
actually really small and convenient you
can take it with you anywhere the head
of your sales channels break down and we
can edit this out if you don't want to
talk about it but I'm curious in the
beginning you had d2c D to C D to C
right direct to Consumer you're shipping
you're handling all of that as you
become more popular and particularly
given the ease of use of your games the
doors open up to using Distributors and
getting placement at places like Walmart
Target Etc right
what does that look like now for you
guys versus in the like what did it look
like for the first three or four games
and what does it look like now so first
three or four games were 100 d2c like
all we did was sold the gamer cell
that's what Kickstarter basically was
right then we moved into Amazon and
Amazon very quickly eclipsed our ability
to sell our own game
and then the retailers retailers went
through this incredible shift they're
like hey our game sections used to have
like four games it used to be like we've
got Connect Four and Monopoly and that's
about it and they said
let's actually build a real game section
and they reached out to us and said
what's it going to take to get you on
the shelf and we said wow anchor tennis
yeah right I mean seriously we were
talking about right place at the right
that's cool man yeah seriously we that's
a big deal it was huge it was huge and
so we got to kind of build the games
departments with them and to say like
yeah you but you got to teach us
everything right we don't even know we
don't know what a shelf is we don't know
what it yeah I don't know what price to
ask for we don't know anything and they
worked with us and we built it together
and it was really awesome and now
I can't give you a retailer by retailer
breakdown but I will say that retail
accounts for about 60 of our business
now what is the remaining 40 percent
it's a mix between
online hobby International and direct to
Consumer what is Hobby oh sorry yeah I
had to learn this too so I mean I know
the word yeah yeah right right so hobby
is this generic term that covers a lot
of things it's it basically means a
store that
primarily sells games so if you think of
a kind of mom and pop
game stores they're typically where
you're going to go to buy more hardcore
games like more strategy games for sure
but they're starting to really get into
party games so they have a lot of
interest in us okay but while we can
sell directly to Target and Walmart
there's hundreds of thousands of hobby
stores so you have to work through a
middle manager to deal with those people
yeah distributor of something yeah
exactly or something like that yep okay
so this is going to strip away the
company for a second because I'm curious
okay
let's just say there's something like
Iron Chef for tabletop games if you want
if you want that you can run with it
I'll take my customer 15 so it's like
the unveiling of the components let's
just say which would be some constraints
I'm not going to give you specific ones
but let's just say you yourself kind of
locked in a room like old school
Japanese manga artists this would happen
like the Publishers would be like you
need to finish X number of issues like
we're gonna keep you fed but you're
going to be in a room until you finish
yeah yeah right yeah all right but let's
just say that you had
a week to design a game okay
you you're allowed to have some play
testers come in for like the second half
of the week generous of you thank you
you're welcome I'm a very lenient
dictator I'm known as the thoughtful
Warden
how would you personally approach it
like you can have pen and paper and all
of the mock-up materials that you need
yeah
how would you go about it first of all
you don't need much more than pen and
paper honestly like that's it so the way
I would go about it is I would say
okay
given this maybe these blank cards and
these Sharpie pens which I travel around
with everywhere like that is all my bag
is filled with and blank cards you mean
like a plan yeah like poker cards stack
of cards white on both sides yeah where
do you get those Amazon uh literally I
ordered them by the palette at this
point it's nuts
because they're so cool right like you
need to design a game you got the cards
you need dice I don't have dice great
I'll take six cards right one two three
four five six shuffle them up draw a
card hey you got dice right like they're
they're everything they're absolutely
everything
so the first thing I would look for is
like what can I do with these very
simple components that creates a core
gameplay Loop that I'm excited about
and I can I can rattle off 12 of those
in an hour that's that's honestly not
the hard part 12 different gameplay
Loops that you're familiar with that I'm
excited about that I can just invent
they're not that hard it's like okay
I'm gonna give
you a card and I'm Gonna Keep a card and
whoever has the highest card wins but
first we're gonna have a conversation
and we're I'm making this up as I go I'm
gonna try to Bluff you like I'm gonna
try to get you to discard your card
because you don't think there's any
chance you can win and you can or still
earn a little bit if I can get you to
fold right right those are easy and come
up with a ton of those and again you
notice
the Crux of that was we're entertaining
each other the conversation is actually
the game the cards don't matter
that's just my Mantra over and over and
over again yep so we do that come up
with a bunch of those and then I need
another person
I need at least one person that I can
show these to play the games with and I
only care about one question in fact we
do all these play tests we don't even
give out surveys anymore there's only
one question we ask which is when you
finish playing the game did you want to
play again
and a game is done when 100 of people
say yes
and it never starts that way it's always
a whole bunch of no's and let me tell
you why and all that stuff but
but that's the only question I care
about
when you finish did you want to play
again and if I can get a little bit of
positive feedback there from a person
showing a bunch of Concepts too and one
of them they say oh let's play that one
again
then you got to start thinking about
okay why did they want to play that
again well maybe they had so much fun
they wanted to play again maybe they
thought they could do better the second
time
kind of a sense of Mastery that maybe
they could achieve by playing again and
I try to identify what that thing is
what that compelling that thing that
kept pulling them back in and double
down on that right that's that's the
thing I want to shine most in the game
start building the surrounding
components all to emphasize that thing
over and over and over again
and then generously you let me have play
testers at the end I'll start showing it
to them that is the point where I've got
my components are done my core gameplay
Loop is done I've got a few of the
peripheral things that are starting
to get those cylinders to fire now let
me put it through the paces and see what
people think
okay so let's say day one yeah so day
one you get you get seated and you're
comfortable yet not too comfortable sell
you have this like hamster bottle full
of coffee good I love it you got
unlimited Ramen and you have a table you
got your blank cards paper Sharpies
what is your brainstorming if that's the
right word to use look like right is it
questions right is it drawing cards
visually or otherwise is just you
sitting there staring at the wall kind
of running through things rehearsing
different things in your mind what would
that look like I think the way that I
approach that is I always imagine two of
me and when I have I need to physically
touch and hold things right so even if
the cards are blank I do need to like
hold six cards and Shuffle six cards and
and so if I'm holding them and I think
okay me standing in front of me
if I were to give you this thing what
conversation could we have it's I think
it's a lot like script writing like I
start with the conflict what is it
that's going to drive the conversation
we can't be getting along we can't have
the same motivation me handing this
thing to you better create a conflict
that now we're going to try to resolve
and that's really it
I think that's where all good ideas
start from is like here we are in a room
you know there can be only one so how
are we going to resolve that because
here we are staring at a bunch of blank
cards
so looking at the company
it strikes me that you have
uh chosen Lanes very well to plan and
what I mean by that is
you have not as far as I can tell maybe
you have so correct me if I'm wrong but
you haven't gone off into the incredibly
complex like 200 game that requires
three hours to get the basics
down after which it requires you know
probably 20 hours of play to get to sort
of intermediate level there are a lot of
those games and a lot of the hobby shops
seem to
favor those games for a lot of reasons
that I think are understandable I mean
the die hards Love Die Hard products
totally what other guiding principles do
you have for instance like two player
versus you need three or four players to
get started
any other
elements that are integral pieces of the
DNA of your design process well first I
gotta say man Tim you ask really good
questions this is fun so this is stuff I
just don't think often about it just
sort of happens so this is awesome all
right
when I was growing up the biggest
frustration I had with games was first
and foremost the instructions like I
just yeah like I don't I don't have the
patience to even read 20 minutes like
let alone the seven hours right to get
into those crazy games and so I really
wanted to make games that you know 10
year old me would really get a kick out
of
um
one of the things I'm most proud of
about our instructions is any of the
instructions you look at the very first
thing your eyes are going to be drawn to
is this box that says hey don't read
these rules reading is the worst way to
learn how to play a game instead go to
our website and we'll teach and we'll
just walk you through it in like four
minutes and we made a video we have a
how to play video and video yeah right
yeah and we did that for every game and
I insisted on it and it's you know it's
expensive but
I insist on that absolutely insist every
game don't read the instructions even
though we spent months working on the
instructions
that's one hugely important thing to me
you should be able to pick up the game
in five minutes and you shouldn't even
have to redo it you should just sit down
watch a thing you're done
second thing is of course like I was
talking about the game just has to be a
tool set for the other players to be
entertaining
I think the other ones though are a game
cannot feel
fragile
I don't mean the physical components I
mean it can't be too easy to cheat it
can't feel like
you shouldn't ever feel motivated to
outsmart the game the game needs to just
say look you already know you've already
got everything you need to play
we're just going to tweak the world a
little bit what if you could only speak
using single syllable words right like
we're not gonna involve too much this
thing will always stand up no matter
what you throw at it
that's really important as well because
at so many games like I have I have a
bookshelf with literally hundreds of
games and so many of them I've realized
like I I accidentally broke the rules
yep the game was just too fragile I
didn't mean to I just it just keeps
happening yeah and then I think also a
game should be beautiful you should look
at a game and smile it should be a
source of Joy these things should be
dopamine engines and part of that is you
you want to hold the thing and show it
to all your friends and that's actually
probably the the actual final one which
is when you're done playing your first
instinct well after I want to play again
your second Instinct I'll say is I'm
gonna put this in my bag and take it to
my buddy's house because I am gonna get
I'm gonna get a little bit of more Joy
by sharing this with someone
and the thing starts to have a life
yeah I'll give you a just an anecdote on
poetry for neanderthals my
recommendation for folks if you play
this first of all your mileage may vary
right always I don't believe that the
whole world is just comprised of of
different size Timbs that's not
the case however my recommendation is
don't do it I and my friends did which
is we decided we were going to play with
three people to a hundred points but you
had to win by a certain margin of points
and that's like not doing any exercise
for six months and deciding you're gonna
do the leg workout from Arnold
Schwarzenegger from 1974. we all felt it
the next day we're like wow some portion
of our brain has not been used in that
way and we really put it under extreme
duress but I do recommend people check
it out I want to flash back to your
mention of the hundreds of games that
you have
as someone who was a super devoted
D player for a long time
which may seem I'll just explain to
folks may seem
to contradict something that I named as
the appeal of a lot of your games which
is the Simplicity d d especially when I
was playing
and I have first edition players
handbook and dungeon Masters Guide and
so on I still have all of my modules and
campaigns and everything is extremely
in-depth but it is also one of the best
games I've ever found for
co-creating a narrative and finding one
another and making one another
interesting and entertaining it is it is
just I mean one of the great Wonders of
the World As far as I'm concerned would
you say it enhanced your friendships
with the players oh 100 I mean there
were these occasional flare-ups as you
might imagine especially if a dungeon
master is in a pissy mood and decided to
really damage someone who was getting on
his nerves it was a but it was the
defining
let's just call it sport of that section
of my childhood because I was a run I
got the [__] kicked out of me constantly
at school there were a handful of other
kids who fit the same description
and we banded together I guess much like
stranger things but minus the aliens and
everything
to play D D it's still great that was
where we could shine but the reason I
bring it up is that I have played
relatively few games I've played a lot
of the classics I've played chess I've
played backgammon I've played Japanese
chess I've played go Etc but now
sort of sidestepping my way nervously
into the gaming World tabletop games
have exploded there are a million
different genres and what I've heard in
in some interviews not not with you but
of game designers is you have to keep up
with the times you gotta watch where the
ball is going and it seems like an arms
race on some level and I'm skeptical of
it good I'm skeptical of that because it
seems like you could end up chasing fads
and you decide oh Pokemon go is really
big people are running through Central
Park tripping over benches and if you do
it incorrectly
you basically just fizzle because that
was a a flash in the pan not to say that
that's true so what I'm wondering about
the hundreds of games that you have if
you were to teach a three-hour class on
the periodic table of elements for games
and you're like these are some of the
canonical games or types of games that
you must be familiar with just like a
chef has to know like salt love it oil
you know sweet sour Umami some of these
basics
what would some of the
candidates be for that oh okay oh yeah
okay stretching here this is this is
gonna be interesting okay first of all
let me say I will admit
I am
a fish out of water here I've never
played D literally ever I've never
played any of those crazy 10 hour
strategy games
I'm missing out on that experience I
would love to have that experience
lately I've been pretty busy so it just
hasn't it hasn't come up I don't even
know how to talk about this but I will
say that I have played a ton of board
games and a ton of card games
and they're you're right there's a
language there's a core ingredient list
that's important
all right the first one that's become
really popular right now
I'm sure there's like a fancy industry
term for it but it's kind of like
it's like a fill in the blank game so
think Cards Against Humanity what do you
mean joking Hazard Apples to Apples and
and the basic structure is always the
same it's
someone else there's a writer's room
somewhere they told a whole bunch of
funny jokes they cut them up into pieces
and now you're going to get credit for
reassembling those jokes that's the
basic principle right so you have a card
it's your turn you play a card
everyone's got a hand of cards you play
your card and I'm gonna not to quote
another game so I'm gonna just make up a
completely false game which is what is
the
best thing I could wear on my head this
is a dumb example but it illustrates the
point everyone else has a bunch of cards
I've got banana beach ball turban
Etc we're all gonna play a card
whoever's turn it was is going to vote
on which one they thought was the best
that person gets a point off we go
there's a bunch of games like that
they're very popular right now it's an
important kind of genre
because it's they're really funny the
the best ones
make you laugh so hard you can barely
breathe they're just incredible
um
let's see where should we go next okay
the next one I think is called I'm gonna
call it deck building and the idea is
there's a whole bunch of cards each card
does something very very special and
Powerful but they're all Community cards
at first and you play the game by trying
to remove things from the community into
your own private stash so that then you
can deploy them and beat the other
players every card has a power and a
weakness you're trying to collect the
best ones you can in order to obliterate
everybody else that's also a very
popular pretty standard one is there a
particular game if someone wanted to do
a uh sort of a chef's menu tasting of
these different games is there one that
comes to mind that fits yeah for that
one there's a game out there called
Dominion which is a very popular yeah
that's a good one to to start with for
deck building
okay next is
of course collectible collectible
trading card games Pokemon Magic the
Gathering things like that
I won't go into too much detail on that
because again I must admit I have never
played any of those yeah I just don't
know anything about them Justin Gary who
came up earlier is a good person to look
into I think he was the youngest ever
national champion in Magic the Gathering
amazing really knows that genre inside
and out so people can check him out yeah
perfect
there's physical dexterity games I
shouldn't physical or dexterity games
and the idea is like to play this game
you have to do something physical
and
whoever does the either the physical
thing the best or makes it so they can
impede other people's physical progress
will win at those kinds of games we we
have one out there it's one of my
favorite games ever it's called Throw
throw burrito yep and it's dodgeball and
card games all mixed into one you try to
collect cards while simultaneously
throwing soft squishy burritos at the
other players collect a card gain a
point get hit with a burrito lose a
point trying to do both those things at
once is where the chaos comes from
foreign
let's see I'm sure there's like a ton
more that I'm missing
how about
I'm kind of glancing over at games here
trying to to get some inspiration sure
and if there are any games where even if
you can't name the genre you're like
really you must play this in the same
way that if if someone came to me and
they said I want to be in a long-form
non-fiction book writer yeah not that I
would be the most qualified teacher of
all time but I would definitely have
certain books in mind where I was like
okay yeah here are five or six you gotta
read there's a few games I've
encountered in my life that have felt so
natural that it doesn't feel like
anybody invented them it felt like they
were just all it's like two plus two
equals four right nobody invented that
they just kind of realized the way to
phrase it um
and there's a game out there called set
that I believe Falls perfectly into that
category
I'm not even gonna describe what it is
because you should just go and try this
game it's a cool game yeah I've played
so yeah it's it is a very cool game it's
one of those games that I used to play
this with my sister who's 16 years
younger than me and so when she was like
10 and I was you know 26 she would
regularly kick my ass at that game and
it's because it activates this part of
your brain that either exists or doesn't
I'm sure a lot of people are just
horrible at it but it is so neat to see
like a master
hit that flow state with this game and
they are discovering patterns that are
right there in front of everybody else
it's just they can see them and you
can't it's beautiful it's just beautiful
side note this is not going to mean
anything to most people but
in my limited anecdotal experience I
would love to know if I were able to
like have a few drinks with the creators
of this game if they find women to get
into those flow States more easily
because I have at least in my experience
seen that and it raises all sorts of
cool questions yeah yeah I wonder how
you describe that skill set like what
what are the words to describe that
skill I have no idea but it's so
beautiful to watch a master it's just ah
makes yeah gives me like chills the last
one I'll say is like I'm trying to find
the right category for something like
Monopoly
because there's a whole genre of game
where it's like Resource Management
resource collection yeah Trading like
Settlers of Catan and so on yeah that's
right
let's talk about Settlers of Catan for a
second because for me
there is a really interesting category
there that is one of the few like
hardcore games I've played and I know a
lot of people would call it not hardcore
but whatever I once challenged a group
of designers I was like describe to me
the core gameplay Loop of Settlers of
Catan and by the way I don't know the
proper way to pronounce that word Katan
Katan yeah media yeah okay tomato tomato
yeah right right right so describe to me
the core gameplay of Katan and all three
of them said the same thing or
variations which was that's a game about
collecting resources spending those
resources to expand the fastest and I
thought that's not what that game is
that's not how I play that game that
game is a social game that game is a
trading game I don't even care about the
game all I care about is my interactions
and and relationships with the other
players because that's how you win or
lose and it was so fascinating to see
that like these are hardcore these are
really experienced game designers we
were playing a different game like
completely different even though we both
read the same rules
so question were they experienced gamers
maybe people don't like that term or
they automatically think digital but
were they experienced game players but
not extremely experienced Katan or Katan
players because my friends who love I'm
just going to say Katan because I'm
American and like heartaches
they do think of it as a trading game
yeah and there's a lot of game theory so
for instance there's some people who
won't make a trade unless it clearly
benefits them but I have a friend who's
very successful and if something doesn't
clearly
significantly hamper him in the early
stages he will make a trade because of
the Social Capital that he builds up the
set of credit for later asking for a
child and he's very successful that's
fair you're right I don't know that they
were successful or experienced Katan
players yeah but that's great that's
really astute yeah I hadn't thought
about it in that context yeah we may
come back to the periodic table of
elements I mean and this is I'm
becoming immersed in this world number
one because I want to spend more time
off of screens I want to also help other
people do that and the way I'm hoping to
do that is by designing a game of
something or collaborating with people
to build again and
I just think that's the only way for me
to really even make an attempt at trying
to understand it is to roll up my
sleeves you invoke the name earlier that
I want to revisit Jordan Weissman yeah
you called him your Mentor who is Jordan
and what are some of the
lessons you've learned or things that
you have modeled from your Mentor so I
met Jordan Weissman at Microsoft Jordan
Weissman is one of the most famous game
designers ever he designed BattleTech he
designed Crimson Skies the list goes on
and on you know when you you go to like
a virtual reality Center and you play
any of these immersive games where
you're like sitting in a big robot
fighting against other robots he
designed all of that and invented all of
that and actually opened the first
virtual reality spaces ever in history
and I met him at Microsoft and at the
time I was hired right out of college
onto this Xbox group and they they had
me they hired me as a producer and
I don't know anything about producing
but I but they hired me and I thought oh
cool I I think I worked in the video
games what does that even mean because
in Hollywood producer can be a million
yeah yeah fair enough what does it mean
in this person in charge of a project
they actually call it the program
manager there it's the person who's
responsible for schedule and budget and
Staffing for a project got it so yeah
they hired me right out of college into
this role and the creative director for
the whole studio was this guy Jordan why
would they hire you right out of college
I was a terrible terrible terrible
student I failed out of many colleges
but I had some really good internships
and the the star internship I got just
talking my way in the front door was at
industrial Light and Magic uh you son of
a [__] yeah right and so I got to work
on Star Wars and I got to put that on my
resume and so
when I applied at Microsoft I basically
said ignore my transcripts ignore my
history Star Wars Star Wars Star Wars
and they said sure yeah come on over is
it true that you're responsible for the
beautiful neck of Jar Jar Banks I like
that you put in the right qualifier
though the neck
yes I did not work on Jar Jar Binks I
worked on the connective tissue on his
neck that tied the CG a face to the
physical actor's body so that it didn't
tear as he moved around that was my job
okay yeah you don't want any injuries in
the Star Wars Universe right at least
unless they're very interesting so all
right so you get hired but you've done
this internship that shines through yeah
you get higher to be the producer and so
they put me on the Xbox they basically
said we need six games
here's 200 million dollars don't [__] up
like that was it and you know I'm sorry
to belabor this whole 200 million
dollars is a lot of money what gave them
confidence that you could go from the
neck of Jar Jar Banks to managing 200
million dollars I mean were there other
safeguards in place that's a lot of
money you didn't give me 200 million
dollars they gave Jordan 200 million
dollars I just worked okay okay okay
okay all right
so Jordan hired me and then and like I
must have been working there for two
weeks where he pulled me aside and he
said
you're a terrible producer like you're
just awful
and I said yeah I know
and he said but like to his credit I
don't know why he said I think you might
be a really good designer so we're gonna
we're gonna switch roles I don't quite
know what it is he saw in me but he said
I'm gonna help train you and you're
gonna help design games instead of
produce them we have very talented
people for that far better than you
let's try this and he immediately just
started throwing me on projects projects
like Halo and saying like go well do
this like go help with this thing and it
was great obviously you know the first
six games for the Xbox that came out
were great
they set the tone for what the Xbox was
and I got a ton of credit again all
because of Jordan because he saw
something in me and said go play in this
Arena instead and maybe the best way to
describe who Jordan is is
years later we'd started a few companies
together and
I right at the point when was this this
was when
George W bush had just won his second
term
and all my friends were upset like
everyone kept oh God the system is
rigged it's not fair you shouldn't have
won again he was so bad the first like
all this stuff I don't care what your
political Persuasions are but like a
whole bunch of people were just
complaining and I would always ask the
same question well did you vote and they
would all say well no it doesn't matter
and I got so upset I was like I just oh
there's just this one tool you have and
you're not using you're one tool and I
sat down with Jordan
and he said you know this reminds me a
lot I was complaining about this thing
all my friends they're not voting and
they and they still have the audacity to
complain about it and he said okay
you know this reminds me a lot of like
the story
of how the U.S was founded
there was there was a bunch of upset
people and they eventually did something
about it and he said you know what we
should do because it's Jordan he said we
should start a clothing company
okay
and so I was like well I'm not following
this at all but yes you know what let's
go let's do it and so what we did was we
started this clothing company where we
made these beautiful shirts like it was
mostly a t-shirt company we put out a
whole line of t-shirts each one was
gorgeous like beautiful we hired the
best artists in the world and just
designed these shirts but every shirt
had hidden inside of it a secret code or
hidden message somewhere in the shirt
and sometimes it was like right on the
printing you had to like fold your shirt
a certain way and get the graphics to
line up and you could read suddenly a
secret message would appear but we use
things like invisible inks we use things
like glow-in-the-dark inks thermal inks
right get your shirt hot and suddenly a
message would appear and if you could
figure out the message you'd take it to
the website you enter in the message and
a little movie would start playing a
little two-minute clip it was basically
a TV show right every shirt had its own
two minute clip they fit together like a
TV show it was episodic and each one
would end in a cliffhanger and if you
want to know what happens next awesome
go buy another shirt and that was our
business model so how did he go from The
Prompt of you being upset about voting
yeah to make the conceptual LeapFrog
move to that because Jordan's like the
most brilliant guy in the world so
the story The episodic story that we
were telling was about a band
and the band
had a very oppressive
producer that was stealing all their
money was just making a huge mess for
them and it got so bad that eventually a
member of the band got murdered oh that
is right really bad and who did it and
and that was the the Crux of the story
and what we never told players of this
game this clothing-based game because
this was Jordan's actual brilliant idea
was as you as you progress through this
the players figured out that this is a
beat for beat retelling of the founding
of the United States and every character
has a historic counterpart right so the
bass player Adam was John Adams the
leader of the band Jeff was Thomas
Jefferson and by listening to the story
and and piecing it all together you're
actually learning the story of the
founding of the country and why they did
it and what they were rebelling against
and why they were so unhappy and why
they created a way for them to work
their way through this system and I'm so
proud to say like
our players like millions of them
started canvassing their neighborhoods
showing up to Rock the vote parties and
they got like I don't remember the exact
numbers so bear with me but it was
hundreds of thousands of new registered
voters through this clothing company
and that's really the beauty of Jordan
is I can go to him with a statement like
none of my friends voted he can say
let's start a clothing company and the
answer is
a hundred thousand more people voted
next time
it's so cool that's amazing yeah so
Jordan may have some unusual hard wiring
that enables him to do certain things
just like Michael Jordan may have some
unusual hard writing that allows him to
jump and do certain things physically
however
there are probably certain principles
certain
Commandments that you could
distill if you had to right so if Jordan
said look you can have
10 hours of conversation with me and
then you have to teach the Ten
Commandments of Jordan Weissman to this
freshman class or it could be a junior
class whatever just let's assume they're
serious I'm not going to ask you to name
10 but do any come to mind that are sort
of quintessential Jordan they don't have
to be Commandments but they could be
anything that comes to mind there's a
few that are immediate because he just
drilled them into my head
one is nothing attracts a crowd like a
crowd and uh yeah try as hard as you
want to Market something get a crowd
that's what actually matters
another one that he
still says all the time is
you've got a violin I've got a barn
let's put on a show right like
don't overthink this just go just like
tomorrow put on the show and you'll
learn a lot and that's fine and you'll
fail and that's fine too just go and
yeah that one was man took me forever to
figure out but it's so important now
does that apply in the context of how
you knew Jordan in the sense and I've
heard other people say this that like
you can think about it for five hours or
you can play test it for five minutes
and you're gonna get the same benefit
yeah something like that that's right
that's exactly it yeah yeah he really
burned that into me
so I started the alternate reality
company with Jordan and if I were in
charge of that company we would have
been paralyzed like I would have been
too scared to do anything but Jordan
called up Steven Spielberg and said we
got this company we can Market your game
better than anybody else in the world
you should hire us and they did and and
we had no product we had no idea what
the hell we were doing and suddenly with
Steven Spielberg we built the world's
first alternate rally game because
Jordan made a phone call
hold on so was he like croquet partners
with the Spielberg Family
Social Club how does that all right so
it was a little different so here's how
this story actually rolled out so I was
working at Microsoft doing this you know
new designer no idea what the hell I'm
doing and one day Steven Spielberg walks
into my office and I seriously right
like and he sits down and he says I
gotta talk to you he says your boss
Jordan
just paid Warner Brothers I don't know
600 million whatever it is for the
rights to my new movie AI
and apparently your job is you've got to
make four video games about this movie
so I thought I should sit down and chat
with you about what this movie is so we
could get started like that's how I met
Spielberg Jordan just sent him to my
office and said
don't talk to that guy
not the worst day yeah man that was a
weird place it was so inspiring so much
fun but yeah like stuff like that would
literally happen every day
huh so the way that actually rolled out
unfortunately like we built four games
we built an adventure game we built a
racing game we built a gladiatorial
combat game and Jordan said look the
thing we really have to do is we need
glue between these things we need a way
to take players from one game to the
other game to the other game right we've
got this incredible narrative but how do
you how do you understand how they all
fit together we need the glue and so we
hired this incredible writer a guy named
Sean Stewart
to write a story about the glue
[Music]
so he wrote it it was you know a
tear-jerker just this incredible
incredible narrative and then the movie
was done we finished all the games we
went to the premiere I don't know if you
remember this movie but like
the movie is about
an Android boy who is adopted by a human
family who eventually all this Android
boy wants us to be loved he wants his
mother's affection and eventually he is
denied that he is abandoned in the
forest no one loves him he's he's left
to fend for himself he Witnesses
everybody die he in fact Witnesses all
of humanity going extinct and never
actually achieves love
and I don't know about you but like I
don't think anybody's walking out of
that movie thinking like I can't wait to
play the Xbox game right like
we went back you're like those people
who came out and they're like I'm really
depressed but I'm not yet ready to kill
myself
how can I push this just a little
further yeah so we went back to work and
we thought oh we gotta it's
heartbreaking but we gotta cancel all of
these games like we just can't make any
of them
so we canceled them but we thought like
that way I know so now presumably when
you sat down and Spielberg's like okay
kid let me tell you what this movie's
about you had some insight into the
storyline and the Arc of this movie so
did it come as a surprise or were you
just like maybe they'll change it maybe
the studio will be like Steven please
Steve baby we gotta change the ending
like to what extent was it a surprise or
were you like Hey we're getting paid
well let's do our best and then it was a
surprise but it was intentional like so
this was a collaboration between
Spielberg and Kubrick right Spielberg
adopted a Kubrick script and he really
didn't want a lot of people to know what
it was going to be about or the final
implementation so we did have the script
but it was a version like 10 versions
back and so it was very very different
but by Design like that was part of
their kind of surprise marketing was
like nobody actually knows what this is
until we're ready to show you
unfortunately we were some of those
people that makes it rougher for the
game designers man
all right so we have to cancel all the
games it was really we spent you know a
year building these things and yeah
sitting down with Jordan like basically
crying just like this is this is the
worst like everything we worked on is
getting canceled now
but we thought you know remember that
glue
that was pretty cool that narrative was
really really good and by Glue you mean
sort of the narrative connective tissue
that was woven by Shawn
Stewart yeah it was again this just
beautiful story it didn't have any
engine associated with it it was just
like
few hundred script pages of the story of
characters that lived in the same world
as Ai and went through it with them
Landing from set piece to set piece to
set piece which at the time were the
Xbox games and we thought like even if
you remove the Xbox games this is still
a beautiful story and I wonder if there
was a way to put it out into the world
and I remember I was sitting again like
heartbroken with Jordan we were at a
sushi restaurant and in Seattle and
I was saying oh there's got to be a way
we can put out at least that story at
least that and and his phone rang and he
looked at me and he said
what if that was the story calling us
right now
and like my brain just exploded I was
just like I have no idea what that means
but it feels really significant and and
so then we sat down and we started
building what is now known as the first
alternate reality game
four Warner Brothers for Spielberg
because we still had this contract we
canceled all the games we had to deliver
something from marketing their movie and
so we decided all right what if we take
this beautiful story cut it up into a
million pieces hide it all over the
planet and let players reassemble it and
the finale of our story is the launch of
the movie which turned out to be called
the beast yeah amazing what a great
story thank you for sharing that yeah so
fun yeah so you have such a broad
spectrum of experience with games and
interactions of all different types and
a human with component player with
player
there's there's such a multifactorial
set of experience you have right now
you have this this company you have many
games
if you were able to
sort of operate under a pen name and
make a game it doesn't have to do at all
with exploding kittens is there some
game they're like God
you know if there were a way if I just
had the time if I could have my druthers
a type of game or anything maybe you
don't want to share it with who knows
but is there something you're like God I
wish this existed in the world and I
would make it if I were just in a
slightly different spot all right I'm
gonna tell you something I'm not allowed
to tell you but I'm going to tell you
anyway
because man you stepped me right up for
this one here goes
so I have two kids I have a
five-year-old and a one-year-old last
year my five-year-old was four and of
course I tried
playing games with her
I hate playing games with her hate it it
is because the games you can buy for
kids are awful they're like if I have to
play Candyland one more [__] time
so I dread it right and she's having a
blast she's just she's getting attention
so she loves it and she's like Daddy can
we play again and I'm just like oh
please no anything anything but play
again I started thinking like this feels
really broken and you know when someone
like Eddie Murphy disappears for a while
and then he does a bunch of kids films
and everyone's scratching their head and
they're like why do you do a bunch of
kids films that's not what we know him
for all right I'm about to tell you that
story
so so I started thinking about like why
are kids games so awful and what I
realized is the model is wrong what if
the model instead it was like Pixar
where you know I was just gonna I I knew
you're I knew you were gonna go to
pictures oh so good yeah so like what if
the kids could have an experience that
they love and the parents could have a
different experience through the same
tool set that they love as well yeah and
so for the last two years every night
with my daughter we get out the the
paper and the stickers and the markers
and we just make games every night every
night and we've we made I don't know 20
30 of these things but a few of them
I'm really good like really good and
and she helped me design them and we
worked we play them all the time and now
she's sharing them with her friends and
I don't want to insult your daughter's
intelligence but she's five currents
right yes so and I mean it's quality
time so it's not like you're like come
on pull it together you need to earn
your keeper out here what does this look
like a non-profit
how do you interact I think this would
be helpful for parents even if they
don't care about game design so my
daughter is still in that phase where
like everything is about her right like
she has no awareness if I'm having fun
or not right everything's about her I
think there are a lot of adults who are
still there fair enough
yeah I can tell you stories there too
the interactions with her the game
design is like how do I make sure that
she's being celebrated that like she is
winning a game but for me what's going
on in the background is I cannot let her
win I have to be trying my hardest and
she has to beat me anyway okay that
sounds hard it's so it's like severe
handicapping it's really hard and we
went through a ton of games where that
wasn't the case where I found oh I'm
letting her win again let's scrap this
thing and try something else and we
eventually ended up with a handful of
games that all satisfy that criteria
that I don't let her win and she wins
anyway that I'm having a blast she's
having a blast and the best thing is
like at the end of it she says can we
play again and I'm like hell yes ah I'm
so glad you asked yes let's play again
and the part I'm not allowed to tell you
but I'm gonna tell you anyway is this
little five-year-old is gonna have a
handful of games in retail this coming
year
that she helped design oh that's so cool
that's so cool oh man getting the dad
gold star so much fun like when she's a
teenager and she's like I hate you Dad
and you'll be like never forget what I
did for you
she's got such a huge perspective like
imagine if she thinks this is just
normal this is what all families do
right you just you make games and you
and you put them and you put them in a
store that's I'm just imagining she's at
the bouncy castle at her friend's sixth
birthday partner oh yeah what are you up
to are you having fun yeah I decorated a
cake she's like oh that's cute yeah I
have three games at Walmart
So speaking speaking of sales this is
going to be an Abrupt awkward transition
but I bookmarked something you said
earlier that I didn't want to interrupt
with at the time but when you were
talking about the first three to four
years of games coming out of exploding
kittens direct to consumer
and then adding to Amazon and you had a
line there was something along the lines
of Amazon eclipsed quickly eclipsed our
ability to sell our own games is that
because when people would search for I'm
just making this up exploding kittens
the SEO was such that people would be
taken to Kickstarter most people are
unfamiliar with Kickstarter therefore
the conversions would be very low but
once it's on Amazon which also functions
as its own search engine but happens to
have very good discoverability on
something like Google that increase
sales or is there something more to it
everything you said is true with one
extra point which is when a Kickstarter
campaign closes
the back this project button changes to
a link to a website
so now there's an extra barrier to entry
you go to the kickstarter page you click
this thing it takes you through to
another page from there you got to
navigate to where the purchase button is
that was too much for people and Amazon
is just here's the buy button right here
do you have any idea I mean this is
going back to the the archives I know
but it just occurred to me that probably
their recommendation engine could not
have hurt you right if you like this
game you may also like exploding kittens
but I don't know if that was a rounding
error or if it ended up adding up to
significant
additive sales do you have any idea
I actually don't know for sure what I
know about Amazon is when we launched
like there were so many stories that had
come out about the phenomenal success on
Kickstarter
that what worked to our advantage was
here's this incredible thing more people
back this than any other project ever
yeah and it made all this money and you
can't have it right like that was the
story right because there was literally
no way to get it you missed the 30-day
window and so when we finally said hey
it's available on Amazon
we had something like 20 000 orders in
the first hour wow it was just nuts
because suddenly it was all right well
nothing attracts a crowd like a crowd
right I mean that's exactly right
because the launch itself became a story
that helped a huge and further
perpetuate the sales right so now we've
got 20 000 orders in an hour now we're
at the top of all the search results on
Amazon you you search for the word game
and it's all exploding kittens right
because the algorithm feeds on itself so
um
I cannot claim any credit for that that
worked in our favor perfectly all we did
was just take full advantage of it and
just kept leveraging it
okay exploding kittens lightning in a
bottle holy [__] now right and you build
this company
which I mean we could we could spend
dozens of hours just discussing the
company building process one of my
questions for you because again this is
serving my interests because I'm curious
in all of this but you don't necessarily
have to name
Voldemort and the things that you don't
like although I'm curious maybe another
time over a glass of wine or something
but with the success of exploding
kittens no doubt you had a lot of
inbound from people who want to option
it or adapt it for different uses in all
sorts of different media and formats and
so on as a company probably at some
point there was at least a discussion of
how can we expand this franchise without
damaging maybe even strengthening our
Core Business yeah what might that look
like
what Paths of exploration have been most
fruitful or enjoyable
oh I like this one okay so we deployed
the same principle after Kickstarter as
during Kickstarter which was
we gotta stay focused for the first
little while all it was was we must
fulfill every single order we made a
whole bunch of promises we thought we
were shipping out you know a few
thousand games we have to ship out 700
000 games our very first order that was
our literally our first purchase order
and it was like okay well that's really
hard
and so we gotta first figure out
logistics we got to figure out
warehousing we got to figure out
everything everything because customer
service right track seriously like I
thought we're gonna fulfill this out in
my garage I'm gonna invite a few friends
over I'll order some pizza and beers
when we're done and 700 000 units is
like
an average game will sell you know maybe
50 000 units a year and we're doing 700
000 in 30 days like it's just nuts
absolutely nuts so the first thing was
stay focused I'm so happy to say we
delivered every single one of those
items on time
with the exception of the orders to
Russia which is a whole other story that
makes me very upset
but we got them out there we got all
right I have to tell you the Russia
story because holy crap all right so so
we didn't have many we had like 16 maybe
20 orders in Russia and we shipped them
all out and
and then we started getting these these
emails from our Russian backers saying I
never got my game and we're like wait
you definitely got your game we got the
confirmation right here and they said
nope never got it all of them nope never
got it so I call up like Customs there's
a special name for it customs in Russia
essentially all of them go through this
one warehouse and I said hey I'm trying
to track down these 16 orders what's
going on and they said oh yeah those
were never delivered and I said well
I've got the confirmation right here
that they were delivered and they said
oh it's illegal to import games into
Russia so our policy is to destroy them
and then mark them as delivered
oh wow
illegal to import games yeah I don't I
never figured that one out yeah there
must have been some some very
interesting political
pissing contest going on I mean I can't
even be getting around my head around
that one like of all the things to to
consider a threat like this this silly
little kitten based card game like yeah
I will say though I have heard many
stories of
first time or yeah in many cases first
time game designers getting themselves
into into financial difficulties because
especially if they have a predominant
overseas backer base
when games are inspected damaged having
holes punched through them and I mean
you can get yourself into a sort of
accounts receivable accounts payable
it's such a huge problem people
underestimate oh man shipping and
insurance on that shipping is so
expensive and everyone expects it to be
free or nearly free and when we when we
show people the bill we're like look the
game costs 20 bucks but it cost us a
hundred and fifty dollars to get that
thing to you and they're just like well
I'll pay 10 of it because that's what
shipping costs
so it's really hard especially for new
game designers
can you not that I'm recommending people
do this but
presumably you can constrain your
Geographic range on Kickstarter so that
you can minimize some of the complexity
here and and I say that this is former
life but I mean I've shipped hundreds of
thousands of units with my first
business real business which is a Sports
Nutrition Company and the stuff that you
run into right especially if something
has in this case
reasonably High retail price and
somebody it gets shipped let's just take
Canada as a simple example it gets
shipped to Canada okay fine you might
say it only costs well I'm throwing this
number out it's it's I don't know what
it is right now but let's say it's
thirty dollars okay fine so you figure
out a way to cover that but then it
lands at their door and they say well
based on this price that customer yeah
you need to pay us this Edition yeah and
then if they don't pay it at the door
they cannot accept the shipment and now
you know what you've just made you've
just made an enemy right because they're
like yeah what the [__] I already paid
you for shipping and now I had to pay
this additional and and it is endless
it's endless I hate shipping so much so
much yeah so don't underestimate the
challenges of of shipping folks you
really need to plan in advance for how
you're going to handle a lot of these
eventualities
coming back to now this could be an
Antiquated interview but I was I was
looking at some notes from a past
interview that you did and I'm just
going to read here maybe it's changed
but we have a completely open door
policy when it comes to new games
designers pitch Us games in person
through our website via email over Zoom
every day
and you mentioned you're looking for
games that have a strong gameplay Loop
simple enough
et cetera et cetera which some of which
we've discussed
has that policy changed that seems like
you could have a tremendous amount yeah
it had to right let's just say even at
that time though
what are some of the other things that
you would be looking for because there
must have been other tent poles you were
looking for if you're getting a lot of
unsolicited submissions I made this
really bad assumption which was that
people who have game ideas have good
game ideas
and so the thing
the Thor were like
hey when I was a kid we used to play
this game and I don't remember what it
was called but it involved three cards
and you're trying to collect four so
let's partner up on it
and I'm just like okay I can I can
dismiss that one email but oh my God
there's like 200 of these a day and I I
don't have time to do my real job and so
so what we had to do was
hire a very talented group of people to
go out and get the games
from things like conventions and and
there's a bunch of inventor meetups and
local meetups and things like that they
filter them they show me honestly not
that many anymore maybe maybe like 10 a
month and they already know what I'm
looking for I've said no to so many of
them that now they understand exactly
the sort of thing I'm looking for what
are some of those things it's a lot of
the stuff we've discussed honestly the
core thing that I'm always looking for
is are players entertaining each other
and that's the biggest fault I find in
almost everything presented to me is I
made this thing it's really beautiful
the game is working so hard to entertain
the players and my response is always
like I don't care about those kinds of
games I don't want a game to be in the
spotlight I want the players to be in
the spotlight stop showing me games that
are working this hard and it's hard it's
really hard to find
it's a great example of focus and
positive constraints I just want to
underscore that at least from my first
perspective as I hear you describing
this because if your Charter is to
create great games you're [__] it's
just so broad how are you ever going to
implement processes
and
follow-up question would be for me
at this point how many employees do you
guys have about a hundred okay
is it necessary to go Scouting For games
is there a cost advantage to doing that
versus just you know whipping those
Geniuses in-house feeding them Twizzlers
right a little hamster wheel yeah okay
so 100 employees
let me talk about what those employees
are doing first of all and why we went
up to 100 right yeah because we started
with two or three and
for a while we were Outsourcing
everything the process of making a game
is not only okay we got a design we got
a PDF here's all the Art here's the
rules done send it off to Manufacturing
after that we outsourced everything we
outsourced the company that manufactured
them we outsourced the company that
would then transport them from that
plant to a warehouse we outsourced the
sales Channel we Outsource the marketing
channels we also just absolutely
everything and what Matt and I decided
to do
was to just we've got this incredible
opportunity what if we just tried to
learn from this as much as we possibly
can what if we just try to be experts at
everything just to see if we can find
the failure points hire smarter people
and then fill those gaps
but remove the Reliance on external
houses and so most of those hundred
people are sales marketing production
Logistics distribution
accounting legal nothing to do with the
actual creative side of the company
because that we can do with a very small
team no it's all the other parts that we
decide to try ourselves failed at it
hired way smarter people and then built
those teams in-house
and it just it helps us become Masters
in this field it helps us not have to do
what other companies do and instead kind
of Blaze our own trail and figure out
like okay perfect example
the exploding kittens box is pretty
small I want a huge piece of cardboard
around it if we had a bunch of external
dependencies we'd fall into the same
category with every other game nobody
gets treatment like that that's
impossible
but now because we're dealing with
Target in Walmart directly literally
calling them on the phone every day and
we deal directly with manufacturer and
we own that cardboard stock and we own
the ink to put on that cardboard now we
can have really interesting
conversations with them about like what
if we put this thing on yourselves and
and we think it'll increase sales in
this way and what if we put a little
secret component in the corner that and
we'll do a whole marketing campaign
about people finding that
it's a kind of conversation that nobody
gets to have in this industry and the
only reason we get to have it is because
we are an end-to-end house
of which very few exist in the world
so end-to-hand house has a lot of sort
of vertical integration advantages let's
say yeah not risk-free no right
100 miles to feed amongst other things
right yeah 100 miles to feed and it
takes fuel to grow
for people who are unfamiliar could you
just give us some milestones in terms of
funding and everything else because it's
a rarity yeah as far as I can tell yeah
I mean it's it's it's certainly not
something that I've come across a lot
and I'm relatively new to the space but
this does seem to stand out so I've
started a bunch of startups this is I
think my fifth or sixth and
every time the Milestones are always
like hey we got we got our seed round or
you know friends and family around and
hey we just got this retail Channel we
just got this distribution deal
for this one it was really weird right
because
we for the first few years of the
company we owned a hundred percent of it
and we had no one to answer to and we
had instead of us going out saying
please please please sell our game we
had people knocking on our door saying
please please please Let Us sell your
game and so the Milestones were really
strange it wasn't we accomplished this
thing it was we allowed somebody else to
do the thing that they were asking for
to sell our game to distribute our game
to Market our game and it went that way
for a long time we had a bunch of people
coming in saying we want to invest in
this thing
and we have this incredible luxury to
say you know money is the one thing we
just don't need like there's all kinds
of stuff we do need but money is not it
yeah so this was maybe the first big
milestone one day
this guy Peter chernin came to our
office yeah Legend in Hollywood
and he said I really want to invest in
your company and we said yeah no thanks
and he said hold on just hear my piss
and he said
you are at the top of your game like
you've you've you've done all the things
you should be doing you've grown as far
as as you should absolutely grow
but the next step is to stop being a
game company and start being an
intellectual property company and what
that means is TV shows movies and theme
parks and it turns out I'm probably the
best in the world at those things
and Matt and I kind of huddled up and
said
yeah that's exactly right like this is a
really good point one that we had never
considered we don't know how to grow
Beyond this point we've done this as big
as we can and so we took an investment
from the tournament group and that was a
huge milestone for us right we had never
had Partners we'd never given away
anything and suddenly we did
and you know I would say we spent like
12 hours fretting that decision once we
signed the papers thinking like oh what
have we done no no there's there's
another Chef in the kitchen what does
this mean and then Peter called us up
and he said
okay if you could make a TV show
who who would you want to make it with
like who's the the top people in the
world and both of us like without
hesitation we're like oh well
Mike Judge and Greg Daniels and again
those those two people are worth
Googling that's Beavis and Butthead King
of the Hill the office office space like
holy crap like the absolute best people
in the world
and we're like but we know and he said
he's like whoa that's a really big ask
and we're like yeah we know but you
asked who would be our number one
choices so there it is and he said okay
cool and he got off the phone next day
he called us up and he said can you come
over to my house this afternoon well I
really want to chat about this TV thing
and we're said sure and we went over to
his house and sitting in his living room
on the couch where Greg Daniels and my
judge and they looked at us and they
said Peter tells us you've got this
really cool game that you want to make a
TV show out of and we should be the
executive producers so can you please
talk to us about it
and it was at that point when Matt and I
stopped it's one of those Spielberg
walks into your office moments yeah
right
like these super powers that some people
have
being able to align with them and saying
like look together
the sum is greater than the the
individual components
Peter's superpower is that networking
our superpowers we've got this really
delightful IP maybe this is a chocolate
and peanut butter moment and it turns
out like and it really was right like
did you say chocolate and peanut butter
I did say chocolate and peanut butter
so the punch line here is like now we
have a Netflix show in development and
it's executive produced by you know Greg
Daniels Mike Judge and Peter chernin and
that's holy crap where this little
startup that started in my garage trying
to raise ten thousand dollars
and now we're like at the absolute top
of the game and that doesn't happen on
our own there's no way we could have hit
that on our own that's that was a huge
milestone in US realizing like it's okay
to give parts of this thing up
as long as we choose really wisely as
long as it's people who share our vision
and want to make this thing bigger than
we could on our own
yeah so for people who are curious the
churning group is TCG
tcg.com portfolio will give you an idea
of some of the properties slash
companies and people they've invested in
they're a lot of very good ones and I
see here food 52 which I know
also meat eater which I know because
Steven rinella took me on my first ever
oh that's awesome I'm actually in one of
the episodes where we went to Alaska
together exploding kittens is right next
to meat here then you have hodinki which
I know because my friend Kevin Rose used
to be the CEO Barstool Sports and it
goes on and on Rooster Teeth which I
have actually been to their offices I
know those guys I don't know them well
but I've been there scopely which I've
actually been looking at more closely
recently hello sunshine which some
people might recognize Reese Witherspoon
they've had very nice outcomes with
hello sunshine and it goes on and on and
on so these guys much like you are good
at Focus they have very particular types
of companies now I don't know if this is
public it might be but like how much how
much money did you end up raising I
don't know if it's public but I don't
mind saying we raised 40 million dollars
at that point
okay so you raised 40 million dollars
now
this is a a world not specific to the
training group although I I'm in some of
the same companies but
I've invested in a lot of mostly seed
stage or series a stage companies but
with that money comes guidance it comes
Health there's certain also expectations
that they have as professional investors
yeah how does that play out okay so
first of all it's important to say that
40 million dollars is still sitting in
our bank account because we just didn't
need it so yeah it's sitting there but
it was important to have as a signifier
right no and just to say it's not so
much the money but like once they have a
portion of the company their hope is at
some point to have a liquidity event
that was really important for me to
understand once you take on an investor
it's not a matter of if you exit the
company is now a matter of when you will
exit the company and that that took me a
second to understand
now the training group is on board and
now we have to have board meetings that
was a new one for us and our very first
board meeting
so one of the partners at the Turning
group is a guy named Jesse Jacobs one of
the smartest people I've ever met and we
sat down with him we're like here's our
first board meeting here's our
presentation and at the end of it he
said that was the worst presentation
I've ever seen
[Music]
yeah and we're like okay well we really
did our best we clearly don't know what
we're doing and so we like to their
credit we worked so closely with them
after that he's like okay you get a
mulligan like we're gonna do this thing
over but let us train you let us work
with you let us hook you up with experts
let us show you other people's board
decks and you'll see what a healthy
company looks like because you you two
have been incredibly lucky and
you have to plan on that not lasting
forever
and they were totally right it was
really important for us to kind of gain
that new muscle and hire a new group of
people we hired our first ever
accountant we hired a CFO that was a
very new thing for us wait wait wait
wait wait you know so you're going in
QuickBooks I mean what what's going on
here if you guys don't have an
accountant well I really love Google
Sheets and so I literally wrote
everything myself holy [__] yeah that
was our first five years like just that
you must have had a lot of free time
yeah I wouldn't call it free time I
would say I had a lot of lack of sleep
that's what I'm saying I'm I'm saying
that yeah fair enough all right okay
okay all right so you get your
accountant
do you start getting systems start
getting systems in place and we start
figuring out like I think the churning
group and Jesse specifically really
started to lead the charge
in terms of like
okay you want to be good at everything
what does that actually mean who do you
have to hire what are the Milestones I
remember telling them we want to try
everything and if we fail we'll get help
that's how we'll know what we can and
can't do and they said great what does
failure mean and I thought oh [__] I
hadn't thought through that definition
and they they just forced discipline on
our company they didn't impose anything
they said look if you want to do it that
way we will support you but you haven't
even defined your terms yet so let's
start there and it was so helpful it was
so helpful God I love those guys like I
said a lot of startups a lot of
investors I have never sung an
Investor's praise like that before
because they just held our hand they're
just like we support you we believe in
you let's do this together
do you
provide Equity incentives to employees
or is it predominantly salary based we
provide Equity to all employees yeah
okay and feel free to
you know plead the fifth or whatever the
legal is on this but I'm curious because
I'm deeply interested in how startup
Founders navigate decisions like these
what percentage of the company did they
buy in their Strategic investment or it
could be a range I'm just I'm curious
what the appetite looks like because
that also
starts to inform the Dynamics that are
at play after the investment closes I'm
specifically not allowed to say
unfortunately okay but what I will say
is what was very important to us is any
terms of any deal that we sign with
anybody we remain in complete control of
the company
we're interested in help we're not
interested in having bosses
okay so is it fair to say they might
approach it like a private Equity
investment but
you want to ensure that you as Equity
holders are in a position to still
retain control of the company that's
correct yeah yeah okay so you have a
tiger by the tail man yeah
I'm not going to dig for more specifics
even though I'm super super interested
personally
because it's kind of part of my
education too we can talk offline how's
that yeah yeah that's fine let's say
this 10 years from now 20 years from now
at some point you'll be like you know
what the the seasons of my life they are
changing
my daughter now has 20 more hit games
than I do
it's it's time to hang up my Spurs
when you have like all the Skittles that
money can buy and you're or just you're
satisfied yeah you've checked that box
what do you think you'll spend your time
on let's just let's just say you're no
longer running
a company of this size yeah
what do you think you'll do
I think the through line between all the
companies I've ever started
that have kept my interest for the
longest is empowering a community and I
love doing that through story I love
doing that
I really hate it when a spotlight's on
me I'm I just I get shy I get I get
weird and uncomfortable
my proudest moment so far has been I was
in an airport and the flight was
canceled or it was delayed the flight
was delayed and it was so late at night
that nobody could get a new flight and
so we had this terminal of all these
grumpy people everyone would they were
just like you know getting on the phone
trying to find new things and getting
turned down and we all realized we just
have to sit here for like four hours and
it sucks and everyone was complaining
and and he just there's this horrible
negative energy and except for this one
group of kids sitting on the floor in a
circle just laughing their asses off and
I couldn't help but like go over to them
and like look over the shoulders and see
what they're doing and sure enough they
were playing exploding kittens and it
was like the
unbelievably beautiful moment for me and
yeah
whenever I tell people that story they
always ask like oh did you tell them who
you were and the answer is of course not
that's the opposite of what I want like
I am so delighted that I could give them
a tool set to laugh with each other and
have this horrible experience
transformed for them into a positive one
and I do not want any credit for that at
all I just want I loved getting to
witness that
we'll set aside for a moment in the fact
that you know here's this 40 something
year old guy staring at a bunch of
teenagers at an airport
but for me it was a very nice moment
think about what comes next it's like I
want more of that I want more of tool
creation
to create those like just little pockets
of joy
and I have a lot of ideas on maybe how
to do it but I don't know which one is
actually gonna gonna be it
someone in my family worked at a
chocolate factory
and at one point they went in loving
chocolate and at some point they just
had too much chocolate and it developed
a different connotation so I'm curious
how
you have
preserved
the desire and
I don't want to say novelty but the
freshness of what you just described in
face of building a company that leads
you to think about games outside of
having the experience of sitting on the
floor with your friends right
I always took a skydiving class like a
week-long skydiving course and at the
end of it I asked the instructor I was
like do you ever get bored of this
and he said do you ever get bored of
having sex and I thought well that's
that's exactly it like that's how I feel
about games like that's how I feel about
this job it's not a thing with an
expiration it's a little dopamine
Factory for me and the people who who
get to have these experiences
I don't know how you get bored of that
that's just Eternal yeah all right well
I suppose yet another vote for more
games in people's lives
so Lon we've covered a lot of ground
we've certainly gone in all sorts of
different directions is there anything
else you would like to add people can
find exploding kittens and
exploitingkids.com and everywhere of
course and there are some Social Links
but you're slowly ratcheting back on
those which I think will be best for
your mental health longevity and pretty
much everything in life is there
anything else that you would like to add
any requests of the audience closing
comments you know something I've been
thinking
a lot about lately is
I've become enamored with Partnerships
all the best things that we're making
now are collaborations with somebody
else way smarter than me
with really interesting perspectives
we just made this game with Penn
jillette from Penn and Teller and it's
like what an amazing brain I can't
believe I got access to that for a few
months and and got to play with him and
what I thought about since then is
we as a company exploiting kittens have
this really unique ability to say all
right smart people out there or people
who have
built followings and built audiences you
know it's a tough statement that you
can't make on your own I made a game
because it turns out it's really hard to
do and I'm I'm really proud to say that
we enable that if you have a
conversation with me and we go down the
path for a few months
can let you say that and that's been so
satisfying lately like we're doing a few
of those and it's just been ah it's it's
so fun it's for a guy who gets very shy
in social situations using that is like
my calling card
oh man I am so set up for Success now I
wish I had thought of that earlier
there are many different types of dance
Partners I mean pendulette is amazing
he's he's been on the podcast I was
looking it was I think 405 so several
hundred conversations ago on the podcast
but what are your ideal dance Partners
like what are what are the
characteristics it's really simple it's
people who love their audiences and you
know maybe that sounds trite but like so
many of the people that I encounter do
not if your audience is a tool for you
to gain money if your audience is like a
means to an end
not interested at all but for those who
are like though I cannot help but
entertain these people if I made nothing
I would still entertain these people if
I had no stage or audience I would still
do this exact same thing
oh I love those people they speak my
language we we just go on for hours so
that's my absolute favorite
so if somebody's listening they're like
hey I think that's me yeah what do they
do they reach out they write to let's
see what's the easiest one these days
if you write to just support that
exploding kittens that's like this
really lovely group email that goes out
to a whole bunch of people I guarantee
it'll make its way to me all right there
you go you heard it here all of those
audience lovers out there
and there are some good ones I mean
there are I will agree with you that it
is not everyone I would say it's
actually probably even on the smaller
side like if if your audience
stop delivering any Financial value to
you today zero dollars can you derive
from this audience would you still
engage
and I think the answer for a very high
percentage is no absolutely right the
love is conditional upon Financial
outcome and I understand that if if you
are making ends meet
and
having to sort of focus on
paying rent and sending your kids to
school and so on like there are
Necessities in life I understand that
however
The Cult of the influencer I find to be
a real amplifier fun house mirror
tendencies in human nature I do think
it's a very distorting
playing field in a lot of sense not to
take this off in a strange Direction
well you're gonna start a whole nother
hour here all right go ahead yeah yeah
well I was just going to say that what I
think folks need to be very cautious of
is even if they start off with the most
sincere of intentions
if you
are not explicitly aware of and take
steps to counter the seduction of the
algorithm
you will be rewarded vis-a-vis your
Audience by more and more extreme
caricatures of yourself
and you will therefore get propelled
into
becoming a mask I've seen this with
dozens of people now where they used to
be fairly moderate in their views their
expression their gesticulation their
volume and now they've painted
themselves into a corner sometimes they
don't even realize it where
the the personality that Their audience
in a sense and the platforms have shaped
them to be is what they are and that's a
that's a very precarious
place to be especially and you've had
this experience if you're on a platform
where you do not own Direct
means of communicating with that
audience and if you have if you have
your organic reach throttled and
suddenly seventy percent of your
positive reinforcement goes away
that is a risky business financially and
psycho emotionally psycho emotionally
especially oh Tim so well phrased like
the reason that I've dropped off of most
of social media honestly is
because it it feels it feels like that's
a precarious place it feels like yeah
it's so easy to be there for the wrong
reasons it's so easy to
by nature of attracting the wrong people
let them shape who you are let them
shape the products that you make
yeah I just I don't I don't see the
value in it anymore and
I'd rather just surround myself with fun
loving amazing people who are nurturing
and help me make amazing things amen
that is where I hope to focus more in
the upcoming year and I haven't had any
social apps on my phone actually I've
had one I had reinstalled Twitter to be
on someone's twitter spaces but that'll
probably come off soon have not had any
social apps on my phone for about two
years now because
I do not believe
that 99.999 of people out there
can overcome armies of data scientists
and extremely effective algorithms with
self-control I don't think it's possible
don't be that person who's like I don't
think I'll get addicted to heroin let me
just try it a few times right
chances I'm sorry you don't have an
immunity bracelet so build build all
right man well this this has been really
lovely so nice to connect and spend time
together thank you such a delight yeah
really really enjoyed it and I will just
say to everybody listening
as per usual we will have links to
everything we discussed in the show
notes at tim.blog podcast
e-l-a-n there are no other guests on
this podcast with that name so if you go
there and search you will find this
episode in the show notes and until next
time just be a little bit Kinder than as
necessary
build more
talk less
and have some fun folks get off the
screens play some games thanks for
tuning in thanks Tim